an excessive cod piece a pair of
improbable shoes and an iconic metal
bikini costumes are incredibly important
in creating indelible characters here
are a few controversial costumes that
made it to the silver screen
in september 2016 audiences got their
first look at jumanji welcome to the
jungle a new adventure inspired by
1995's robin williams led adaptation of
the children's book of the same name in
the photo dwayne the rock johnson kevin
hart and jack black are each wearing
jungle appropriate outfits alongside
co-star karen gillen who's wearing what
amounts to child-sized clothing the
photo prompted immediate criticism
prompting gillen to try and defuse
controversy by telling the hollywood
reporter the payoff is worth it i
promise
it was later revealed that the first
footage for the film really did explain
gillan's skimpy outfit as thr recapped
the plot involves four high school
students who are forced to clean out the
basement of their school while in
detention they find an old video game
and each chooses a character to play
helen's character is a shy girl who
transforms into her adult character and
as viewers saw in the film's first
trailer the costume choice is a
reflection of the way video games often
portray women
joel schumacher's batman and robin is
usually seen as a disaster setting aside
the cartoony elements the terrible
dialogue seven million
never leave the cave without it
and poor plot choices fans will never
forget the movie costumes specifically
the bat nipples schumacher explained in
a behind the scenes special the
inspiration for them are greek statues
that have perfect bodies
and so we're molding this perfect body
in rubber and they're anatomically
erotic so it never occurred to me not to
put nipples on the men's suits because i
didn't know the male nipple was a
controversial body part that sounds
reasonable enough and if batman and
robin had succeeded on many other levels
audiences might have been able to look
past the costume distractions
unfortunately the movie sent the entire
franchise into limbo for almost a decade
leaving fans with years to mock the
worst misstep in the franchise's long
cinematic history
an all cgi green lantern original stills
and trailers for the 2011 film looked
pretty awful and although the studio
insisted it would look amazing on screen
the animated costume has been widely
held up as one of the many reasons for
the film's failure star ryan reynolds
later admitted to screen rant that he
didn't care for the cgi ensemble saying
i mean it's brutal doing a film where
you're wearing a motion capture suit for
the whole time i didn't even get to see
the green lantern suit until the first
trailer i never even knew what it looked
like the filmmakers wanted to do
something new for a superhero and
costume designer nyla dixon came up with
the idea that the suit was his power
manifesting outside the body an
interesting idea but the special effects
just didn't hold up dixon agreed as
reported by entertainment weekly we were
literally doing what you would sculpt in
a studio but we were doing it with a
computer
in many respects we were following all
the same principles but you never got
the tangible result that you get from
the build you do in a costume house
even before pitch perfect 3 made its way
to theaters the production caught flack
for potential discrimination against
their plus-size stars rebel wilson
posted a photo online of herself
alongside co-stars britney snow and
chrissy fit while the latter two were
wearing sleeveless tops wilson was in
short sleeves
the photo prompted accusations of size
discrimination arguably intensified
since wilson has been a public advocate
for a healthy female body image
the controversy intensified when people
pointed out that esther dean one of
wilson's co-stars also wore a similar
sleeved version of the striped sailor
top movie costume designer salvador
perez ultimately took to twitter to try
and put out the fire i let each actor
decide how their costume fit it was
their choice rebel esther and hannah may
wanted sleeves in another photo posted
by kelly jakel each of the stars are
seen wearing a variety of styles of the
same sailor top it appeared that the
photo that ignited the controversy in
the first place may have been taken out
of context
harley quinn's big screen debut in david
ayer's suicide squad was one of the
movie's biggest draws especially since
margot robbie was playing the famed
villain as with any other comic book
character a lot of media attention
focused on her movie costume
particularly how little of it there was
robbie shared her thoughts on the tight
costume with the new york times as margo
no i don't like wearing that i'm eating
burgers at lunch time and then you go to
a scene where your host down and soaking
wet in a white t-shirt it's so clingy
and you're self-conscious about it
ayers stated he didn't think denim
overalls would be appropriate for the
character and insisted robbie understood
the character's iconography
you may have a point harley initially
wore a jester suit in batman the
animated series but over the years her
wardrobe has changed significantly as
the character went from being a jester
to more of a sex symbol who's now made
her way into hollywood hot pants and all
what
everyone's seen photos of marilyn monroe
standing on the subway great in a
free-flowing white dress
the shot filmed for 1955's the seven
year itch was totally intentional but
the filmmakers didn't imagine it would
cause such a stir costume designer
william trevilla didn't think it would
become his most memorable piece
he took care to craft an outfit that
would convey marilyn's sweet innocent
nature while still letting her sexiness
shine through the dress was hand pleated
with metal boning and made in an ivory
crepe it didn't take a genius to
discover that filming monroe in public
might generate some buzz for the 7 year
itch so they shot on a real new york
street invited 100 photographers and let
a crowd of over 2 000 watch the action
photographer george zimbable was there
and said the crowd went 50s wild every
time monroe's dress flew up
oh do you feel the breeze in the subway
isn't it delicious
the crowd loved marilyn and she easily
stole the picture but one man was
definitely not a fan of the stunt
baseball star joe dimaggio monroe's
husband at the time unexpectedly arrived
at the raucous set after watching his
wife get oggled and hollered at he
decided to leave zimbabwe recounted the
moment they were very publicly leaving
and everything stopped for their exit
there was a changed mood on the set and
everyone could feel it apparently monroe
and dimaggio got in a terrible fight and
the next day on set monroe needed makeup
to cover the bruises though the
revealing dress wasn't the only problem
in the marriage it did seem to be the
straw that broke the camel's back as
monroe filed for divorce three weeks
after the infamous scene
princess leia's metal bikini struck an
immediate chord with male fans of the
star wars series from the moment it
debuted in return of the jedi but not
everyone fell in love with the slave
leia outfit in fact many viewers found
it to be a prime example of
objectification and pretty poor
treatment of the series only notable
female character at the time carrie
fisher who played leia and had to put up
with decades of discussion around the
outfit warned newcomer daisy ridley
during a discussion with interview
magazine don't be a slave like i was you
keep fighting against that slave outfit
the costumes designers insisted they
never intended the costume to be
demeaning and based the design off rank
for zetta's artwork for the cover of a
princess of mars george lucas loved the
idea and since he wanted something
special for the scene he got it fisher
got extra attention while wearing the
get-up for more reasons than one since
it was literally made of metal the
outfit wouldn't stay in place though
fisher may not have loved the outfit she
refused to be victimized by it decades
later she pointed out on twitter that
the character's brief time in captivity
ends with her killing jabba with her own
chain that chain only enslaved me until
i could use that frabjess thing to kill
that drooling swollen super tongued slug
and whirl him off into infinity as
always fisher had the last and best word
you may have blocked it from your memory
but ryan reynolds played deadpool before
his solo outing in deadpool
unfortunately during his first
appearance as the character in x-men
origins wolverine the filmmakers decided
to make the brave choice of doing
everything they could to insult the fans
they took away his suit including his
mask and they sewed his mouth shut
leaving a character who's literally
referred to as the merc with a mouth
physically unable to speak
even director gavin hood admitted
deadpool came out all wrong in his film
explaining it was hard to fit deadpool's
personality into a pg-13 movie
studio adi who applied the creature
effects for the film made a video
explaining their whole side of the
deadpool tale the artists believe the
studio didn't intend for deadpool to be
fully formed in wolverine just to set up
for what he could become in a later film
one artist suggested if you think of
this as an embryonic deadpool it might
make more sense from the comics to the
screen the dc superheroes attire has
been the focus of attention numerous
times over the years so it's no surprise
that from the second gal gadot signed on
to play wonder woman in the dc extended
universe a number of comic readers
immediately chimed in about how wrong
she was her performance in batman vs
superman silenced many who claimed she
was too thin and didn't have a hero's
figure but the controversy didn't end
there the amazonian's latest costume
seemed fairly appropriate
though a lot of people were unhappy
about the shoes wonder woman has to run
around and kick butt in heels which many
argued were unnecessary and put the
emphasis on sexiness over strength
though heels might not be the most
practical thing for a superhero the rest
of the movie costume was thoroughly
thought out designer michael wilkinson
spoke to the hollywood reporter about
his ideas behind her signature look
saying
we wanted to create something incredibly
strong and portray her as a legitimate
fighter there was a lot of love that
went into all the details making her
really look like a powerful legitimate
warrior
though audiences generally loved the
dinosaur action and the guy carrying two
margaritas as he ran from prehistoric
monsters there was one big problem with
jurassic world bryce dallas howard's
heels howard played claire an uptight
executive who ends up running around in
everything from mud to wet concrete and
never for a moment takes off her nude
pumps
even when escaping a t-rex those heels
stay glued to her feet it's not hard to
see why audiences had a problem heels
would be the worst possible shoes to
wear in that situation
the pumps must have been made of magic
since they never came close to falling
off in any of her off-road adventures
but howard defended the choice to yahoo
news saying
i'm better equipped to run when i have
shoes on my feet i think she's somebody
who could sprint a marathon in heels for
me it was actually logical for her to be
in that very illogical situation because
she doesn't belong in the jungle and yet
she finds herself there and has to adapt
whether or not you like the pumps you
have to be impressed by howard's ability
to run in them without breaking an ankle
judge dread is less than great for a
number of reasons one being a lot of
screen time for rob schneider and
another being the ridiculous way
sylvester stallone hollers
but for long time fans of the character
that wasn't the worst of it in the
comics judge dredd famously never takes
off his helmet but sylvester stallone
takes it off in under 20 minutes
director danny cannon's original idea
was to keep dread dark violent and nc-17
he wanted the film to stick closer to
the comics and have an overall gritty
tone stallone on the other hand wanted a
flat out comedy according to canon
stallone wanted countless rewrites and
always pushed for more laughs plus he
had a less than reverent view of his
character
dread a role model you've got to be
kidding this guy's a nut
in addition to making script changes
stallone also wanted to say in the
character's fashion the movie costumes
were partially designed by emma porteous
and gianni versace as stallone wanted
the fashion designers take apparently
versace thought the future would run on
cod pieces since they were heavily
featured in his original unused designs
alan grant co-writer of the dread comics
said the story was subservient to
stallone who i think takes himself too
seriously
when carl urban was announced as the
star of the 2012 dread reboot he
immediately assured fans he'd be leaving
the helmet on
i am the law
much darker than his usual muppet fair
jim henson's 1986 fantasy film labyrinth
is about a teenager named sarah who gets
sick of watching her baby brother toby
when her little brother gets kidnapped
sarah is whisked away to a magical land
of goblins and other creatures in this
other realm sarah matches wits with
jareth the goblin king whose romantic
interests in her are deeply off-putting
his overly tight trousers and prominent
cod piece being in a children's movie is
another issue altogether jareth is
complex and charismatic a sort of
mythological rock star who's attractive
and frightening he's portrayed by
real-life rock star david bowie who
brought sex appeal and danger to the
role costume designer brian froud played
up all of that when creating the
wardrobe for jareth he recounts this in
the documentary inside the labyrinth
he's contemporary with a leather jacket
it has armor on it i gave him a swagger
stick it has a crystal ball but if you
look at it it's a microphone you're
supposed to be a young girl's dream of a
pop star we got in a lot of trouble
about maybe how tight his pants were but
that was deliberate because 70s and 80s
rock stars wore tight pants on stage and
in music videos almost as an aggressive
display of their sexuality so did jareth
during hollywood's golden age the major
movie studios all agreed to a
self-policing system of censorship and
adherence to standards of decency
according to npr former u.s postmaster
general will hayes developed a list of
36 don'ts and be carefuls nicknamed the
haze code that filmmakers dutifully
followed for more than 30 years even
though they weren't enforceable laws
celebrity billionaire howard hughes
dabbled in filmmaking and directed the
outlaw a 1943 western about a vampy
revenge seeking femme fatale named rio
mcdonald the movie starred jane russell
in her feature film debut and she wore a
lot of revealing costumes in the film
all of which accentuated her chest even
the advertising heavily marketed
russell's animal magnetism using photos
of her reclining on hay bales and a
loose-fitting blouse without a brawl
underneath to drum up the film's
publicity during production hughes was
disappointed that his cinematographer
wasn't capturing enough footage of
russell below the neck and above the
waist he also didn't want shots of the
actor's chest to include any trace of a
bra which was a provocative notion for
the 1940s so hughes used his aviation
engineering background to design a
seamless push-up bra for russell which
would be invisible underneath the
actor's wide open blouses hughes got the
sexy shots he wanted but once he
submitted the final cut of the outlaw to
rko pitchers it couldn't pass the haze
code without the careful deletion of
some of the raciest images of russell
princess merida from brave has been
hailed as one of disney's least
princessy princesses from her refusal to
marry to her amazing archery skills and
her insistence that her curly hair run
free audiences felt merida was a step in
the right direction so it was all the
more disappointing when disney dolled
her up later on making a controversial
costume that wasn't even on screen
when merida was officially announced as
the 11th disney princess the corporation
debuted a new illustration of the
scottish lass and a number of fans
weren't pleased the 2d drawing gave
merida a slightly slimmer figure bigger
eyes and an all-around more glammed up
look brave co-director brenda chapman
didn't mince words when little girls say
they like it because it's more sparkly
that's all fine and good but
subconsciously they are soaking in the
sexy [ __ ] hither look in the skinny
aspect of the new version it's horrible
merida was created to break that mold to
give young girls a better stronger role
model a more attainable role model
something of substance not just a pretty
face that waits around for romance
disney responded to the controversy by
saying all the princesses are given new
looks from time to time and that
particular version of merida would be
one of many the company argued it had
chosen that design because merida would
want to dress up for the special
coronation the fact that merida hates
getting dressed up and brave and tears
apart her fancy gown at the first
opportunity didn't factor into the
character design apparently
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]